hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the moon okay we're
still the carnival and Johnny just ran
off somewhere ever to be alone in moody
so I guess we need to go find him and
then talk to him about its problems so
that we can get to the bottom of this
whole moon thing now like just got our
minds blown because Joey or Johnny had a
Johnny Joey had a twin brother named
Joey that's actually hard sentence to
say and this is weird because there's
got to be some confusion in his life as
to his identity versus his brothers god
that's just so sad though way to follow
mom's orders huh yeah yeah you berate
him all you want you just need some time
alone to think maybe find River oh well
wonder what that has to do with his idea
to be special you know like in his
teenage years in high school in the
cafeteria said that he wanted to be
special it's got to find out why what
are you doing what you doing kiddo what
you doing
alright fine be that way you want to
talk to me I don't want to talk to you
Wow there you go look at the Stars this
beautiful space it's a glorious
adventure waiting to happen
also the birdies are there so that's
cool too
whoa whoa exactly what I said man I know
I know
well okay so we wandered off the trail
and found a cool place well let's face
it he could have also been eaten by a
pack of Tigers Tigers don't travel in
packs idiots
who's this an expression you know when I
was a kid my grandpa took me stargazing
every year yeah there was a hill outside
of the city that would stand the same
one every year we'd watch the stars till
daybreak well I did mostly he just
carried the telescope for me of course
the thing was though ma didn't want me
to stay up late grandpa always told her
that we were just camping and hid the
telescope inside the car that's all good
but when we got back in the morning I
had to pretend like I actually slept
so in conclusion that's the story of how
I started my caffeine addiction
hooray caffeine good for all ages yeah
you're terrible I know it's a shame
though yeah it's a shame that's what I
want to do I want to go on the desert
and see the stars out there where
there's no light all the nice memories
lost and never found and who knows how
many more like it well as you say just
take it moment for moment right mm-hmm
Oh bloom Laura I told you they were
packs of tigers dwelling here is it the
brother who goes there oh it's River
it's a little baby river oh it's
adorable
don't run I'm nice I swear I'm Johnny
what's your name
you're at my spawn your spot oh I'm
sorry I didn't mean hog this place all
to myself um you want to join me are you
here to watch the stars are you
hey it's adorable
adorable
ooh cutscene that's really what I want
to do I want to go to the middle of the
desert where there's no civilization and
no lights around that can pollute the
sky with light pollution so that it
looks like that I want to actually be
able to see the galaxies and the stars
just look at him oh I'm looking did you
know there were so many lights in the
sky yes
oh I did too you said this was your spot
right only during the carnival not a fan
of the crowds me neither
I'll just talk for the both of us don't
worry about that you know you saw and
told me your name yet I'm not telling
you
everyone makes fun of it in school why
the same makes them want to go to the
washroom okay then
well it can't be worse than John I mean
everywhere in the world nearly
everyone's named John even in India
probably but I drowned well I know
what's wrong with that
hmm what's wrong with having a name that
everyone has well its boring I guess I
mean if everyone has it then what's the
point
I wouldn't mind just for once to have
the same name everyone else's has
everyone else has
it's like those lights in the sky they
all look the same premiere that doesn't
make them any less pretty dull I suppose
what do you think of those stars up
there anyway what do you think those
stars up there are anyway
my dad said those joining their giant
burning spheres of gas if I could talk
well I bet he's just making it up yeah
whatever
why would he lie to me because you know
that's what cooling ups - they make
things up
Santa Easter Bunny kangaroos stuff like
that they're fireflies that flew up too
high got stuck in the sky have you ever
ever made an Easter Bunny out of stars
like a constellation yes um of other
things
never try to rabbit though do you want
to make one yeah we'll make the bestest
constellation ever let's see who makes
one out first I see a circle
I see I found a hedgehog all curled up
okay we'll start with three great go one
go and start I see it huh where in the
sky um but where in the sky think big
huh it was a bone bigger than all the
others I don't know
wait a minute wait a minute here I see
tell me what you see there right there
the two years ahead what else and
they're there it's two feet yes what
else and in the moon the moon in it is
its big round belly I kind of see it I
guess
iron is yeah that's what I see and I
thought is that what she wanted him to
describe when he was like when she was
looking at the rabbit and showing him
the rabbit so what do you think they
really are oh that's what the rabbit was
the blue and the yellow the yellow of
the starsin oh maybe I don't know the
Stars I mean I hmm I've never told
anyone but I've always thought they were
lighthouses billions of lighthouses
stuck at the far end of the sky Wow must
be so lively up there but it is they can
see all the other lighthouses out there
and they want to talk to them but they
can't because they're all too far apart
from what the others are saying all they
can do is shine their lights from afar
so that's what they do they shine their
light sent the other I'll at the other
lighthouses and at me why you because
one day I'm gonna befriend one of them
that bag what's in it
oh it's surprise I won from a whack
Amole did you get to play that game
I tried but I'm too clumsy what did you
get from it I got a thing
a platypus I don't really know what it
is is that a plan of us as a platypus oh
it's a part of us he gave her the bus
some got a weird duck beaver thingy may
I see it it looks so strange I wish I
could win one myself well yeah just one
Johnny eek oh that's ma ma callin here
you know what keep it it's yours mine
yeah I can always get another I like to
brag but I'm totally the best of the
game way better than my brother Joey
Johnny will you be your next year yep
will you yes same place same time yes I
was so adorable what if you forget or
get lost then we could always regroup on
the moon
silly Oh on the rabbits tummy ah tonight
coming oh oh yeah I forgot my hacky sack
in the bag you said you're clumsy right
maybe it'll help dog get so juxtaposed
by all the sadness that I know comes
later yeah because I guess the lesson is
that it doesn't change the meaning of
what happened just because something bad
happens in the future doesn't mean that
the memories of the past are don't have
meaning unless that's not the Provence
statement then I'm supposed to get out
of it then I just supposed it's actually
no important lesson anyway so it is what
it is stupid hair try to fix it work
ha ha there we go if they ever get lost
wait does that mean don't tell me you
didn't see that coming
no and here I thought this is gonna be
an inspirational childhood dream story
he doesn't remember he doesn't remember
the fact that he met her I should have
known that some girl would come along
and turn it into a cheese fest
I suppose now we know what we must do to
send him to the moon wait you're not
actually gonna do it are you it's our
job Neal Oh No
well I guess yeah it's what we were
contracted to do he has to remember that
he wanted to go to the moon all along
damn it Eva Eva Eva mm-hmm
I need a haircut I know oh man sorry is
getting a little wonky guys oh boy I
know you're in here oh yeah there dang
where are you Eva what you doin Eva Eva
Eva
we are Eva why is it girl get back here
turn around Eva Neal I know what you're
planning to do I know I know that you
know yeah well I know that you know that
I do look our contract is to send him to
the moon the only way for that to happen
is if Johnny is motivated to do so but
that means removing River then what's
the point the reason why even wants to
go the moon in the first place is
because she died I know we are legally
bound by the contract to specifically
loot the contract I didn't take this job
to make him miserable Eva I know about
you but I signed up to help the freakin
geezers die happy me too and I like this
job if we directly go against our legal
obligations we'd be in for court
hearings
appeal I know that Johnny be happier to
not go to the moon Johnny would be
happier with a lot of alternate life
tangents Neil we are not here to play
God our job is to give him what he
signed for well we know what he wants
better than he does look I'm only
risking losing River because I believe
in her hand
what do you mean risk you're removing
her and besides I will make up for it
make up for it how oh boy
running out of time just trust me whoa
okay bye
says the one who pushed me off the
bloopin lighthouse oh boy oh that okay
well things got a little wonky did you
just
oh boy freaking light data abusing your
powers doesn't disable my controls
entirely IVA oh wow whoa hello what the
hell movie traps just try to buy some
time do you thanks for telling me how
was that oh now I'm numb oh whoa okay
then all right I gotta I won't know it
oh god damn it yeah I gotta be careful
I'm probably ro hello okay those are
some expensive pieces of equipment or
toss saying piss off
come on come back man we're yet Eva wait
this is not the right away is it
oopsie-doopsie sorry wrong turn okay up
here
no I guess I'm looking for her so I
don't know if there actually is a time
letter anything that's gonna change look
don't make me exit this whole thing and
unplug you would you really risk
distorting his memories as they are just
stop trying please this won't take long
on again or come and find me at the end
of the hall
oh boy oh so now wait can I move with my
mouse my keyboard all the time that
would have made life a lot easier
sometimes the hell is going on here ah
hey now oh you've got to be freaking
care is this a joke to you Eva
oh they're zombies they're Lord they're
just zombie Eva's there's some people's
huh all right then do come any closer I
got plans what I'm gonna shoot my plants
whoa all right then I shot my plants
uh-oh wait whoa wait whoa hey whoa whoa
what are you wait daba shoo plants in
you can't gonna like my plants oh yeah
that's ridiculous
that's ridiculous wait what who these
things are good for something after all
oh they blocked off the zombies good
lordy Lou this is ridiculous what's
happening I'm coming for you Eva whether
you like it or not ama coming for you
wait a minute what the how long is this
hallway whoa hello there hi frog okay
alright okay god oh god don't do that to
me ma
not again I shan't tolerate your
insufferable neisha okay so good Linda
this whole thing is just a loop okay so
I need to go somewhere else besides
there Oh
bloob this okay well alright then whoa
all right I tossed him with my mind what
da yeah alrighty then you can't hide
from me Eva
I'm a-comin for you you got it got it
once I find you even what happened
Eva yeah it's me the NASA agent the
agent from Nassau whoa what the what
else
billions of lighthouses stuck at the far
end of the sky
now the whole constructs messed up just
tell me what it is whoa what the hell
I've always thought they were lighthouse
Wow why is even the bed in little widen
world
Eva's messing things up bad hello it's
finished River she won't be alone
anymore what I just I just don't want to
be another typical kid in a sea of
typical people Nick got a John obsession
was it like there's our responsibilities
I suppose badge is all the memories
rolled into one
oh oh I'll follow you bunny I guess it
helps you understand her condition I'd
rather not why is that well because
you're a douche I guess I don't know
what's going on here
all right then thank you I know what's
going on all righty then I'll follow you
okay so the song is playing is that a
good thing or a bad thing you're dancing
on the lighthouse that's so sad
yeppers new clothes which I never read
Oh God
the fields are all mixing up in the
world no not this one hello wait don't
go I'm Johnny what's your name that's
the kid after he got hit by the car
you're spot on sorry dude
oh good I'm Johnny oh it's our ball ah
look it was a long time ago there's no
date or time Johnny no dinner time
Johnny oh god it's so horrible what's
happening Ling Ling Oh answer Oh
everything's gone nuts hello Neal
Morpheus what it's Eva you idiot no
shwoo
we're the only ones here listen whatever
you've been doing stop it
we might not know what Johnny wants but
what we know what he doesn't want what
he doesn't want is exactly what you are
accelerating it's already done Neil oh
boy why don't you come out now oh thanks
thanks Eva thank you
No No thank you so much you're just
delightful IVA are you well you got the
shadow people to drag her away what did
you do to her lack she's merely going
elsewhere
you
you know it's one thing to disable my
controls to feed me some olives but this
is way out of line I'm sorry but this
just won't go anywhere if you keep on
resetting the memory at this point this
is the only way I'm asking you to trust
me
so please is calm down and wait here
then just pull the trigger already where
are you going
is this one last thing I need to do
hoser there's no need to visualize a
door what's with all this melodrama Neal
are you fighting so hard for this forget
it
there's no time everything will be all
right man is turnaround okay all right
hey I add mooing shoosh man um hello oh
she's gone
sorry kid
it's already started ah
ah come on I can hog all the good tables
they're all the same sheesh not ceilings
right the ones by the kitchen smell
better Judy and olives revealed her
juicy step Oh Oh Zoe oh my god I knew
that had to be something about it
because he had to remember his past here
to remember that he wanted to go the
moon in the first place
Oh God I don't know if it's better or
worse what am I supposed to think of
this is it right to change the past
saving him doesn't justify it you'll
always find another river Neal but you
only have one brother come on we're in
the way
shortstop deep breath
everything has all right Chinna I can't
step into the spotlight
she said I'm somehow without any words I
just stood there searching for an answer
when this world
to
they empty from the sky but I told mine
if you're with me everything
why do my words always lose their
meaning I feel what I say there's such
her theft between them he said I can't
really seem to read you I just stood
there never know what I should do when
this world is all see I'll ask you to
fly away with me
the empty from the sky but I don't mind
if you are with me everything
if you're with me and everything
you
oh man
oh man it's watching watching all the
memories change I don't know if it's
right to give him happier thoughts if he
doesn't even know that he lost anything
what does that mean you sound surprised
whatever happened to we always succeed
because we are awesome this isn't a
success Oh lighten up we're in NASA we
don't have much time left let's at least
check this place out oh my god I I don't
know what to think of that I don't know
what to think of the idea that you
change your past but you lose so much of
what you've actually experienced please
wait here someone will come and show you
around sure link it's just like the idea
of it to the moon the story about a lame
ducks attempt to become an astronaut I
can't believe this crap actually sold
this isn't the real world meal how
pathetic all this trouble for just some
girl that's what I thought you'd say
Neil how pathetic all this trouble just
for some girl there you go good dab you
back yeah yeah she she really likes his
backpack wait hang on before I go down
there let's see what's over here oh man
cuz I know at the end of the day this
all isn't real his experiences are still
what they are even if he doesn't
remember him but I mean part of what got
him into this is because he doesn't
remember his past in the first place
like what would happen if he actually
you know the the whole beta-blockers
thing to erase his memory what if that
never happened how would that have
changed his life across four bars and
memory links
am i able to go up here I need to find
some stuff
zamir's this elevator smaller on the
inside to the second floor I'm pretty
sure I need to find a memory link on
every floor if there's four floors why
would there be this is all made up like
how's the machine just make up
everything like this how does it do it
it's just fake this is the Mission
Control Center how much going on now but
you'll see a live one day a half
expected to sees or down on that screen
it's not here oh your base I belong to
me
let's go Dan so so such such an
interesting question to pose something
so strange to ask like why or how if it
was even possible so do you think last
century's moon landing was let's not
kneel that's not real and don't get me
started on how much more we should be
funding NASA but that's a whole nother
story
alright and here's the centrifuge if
you're lucky you'll learn to hate it one
day I asked the spinny thingy it's not
here either are you talking about come
on we don't have long left what is he
looking what is she looking for I mean
she she did this this was her job and
she did it I guess that's good your
records are excellent but we'll have to
monitor your stats status closely in the
coming sessions okay good
go on they're waiting for you in the
other room they're gonna spin you around
in a spinny do daddy and you're gonna
puke and everyone's gonna look at you on
mark your record tests and then laugh
the real NASA demure
oh man I missed the simple puzzles I'm
putting together roadkill things got too
complicated shuttles sent still under
heavy maintenance we may only view it
from here for now uh this isn't good
perhaps there's somewhere we missed you
need to work on your communication
skills
the shuttles still under heavy
maintenance blah blah blah I got you
where's the last memory whoa yeah you
know what's the best part of it what the
very top in the bottom of the shuttle
I'd have to agree oh how I pity anyone
who can't see those particular parts oh
I got you
indeed especially its nose at the top
when maintenance finishes it probably
won't look the same yeah now's the only
time Oh joyous day oh good job game show
talking about something I can't see very
funny that joke hasn't been done before
Jack think it has been but I can't
remember okay so I gotta go to floor one
now I can progress through the doors oh
man anyway I'm all out of time for this
episode I don't know if it's gonna end
but I feel like there has to be a bit
more of a resolution to this than just
this like you can't just be as memories
change and that's all can't be all so
either way I'm gonna end this episode
here if the ending what other ones just
short but I'll add it to this one be the
way thank you all so much for watching I
gotta think about some stuff and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
hey you keep knocking them down there
sorry
not even a little bit sorry that's how
they got past us last time you [ __ ]
ah no [ __ ] out oh I'm gonna getcha I'll
getcha Varga mr. drew [ __ ] out